[Music]
hey welcome to cluelessgamer with me
conan o'brien today we're going to be
looking at connect star wars i'm going
to be honest right up front i don't know
a lot about video games i didn't even
really play them back in the 80s devoted
most of my
extra time to my hair i don't know about
this stuff but i'm going to use my good
friend's knowledge here aaron blair
hello aaron is my assistant in all
things the web yep that's right
and you can take a punch
i'm gonna start this game using my phone
all right here we go you know i always
knew master luke would grow up to be a
jedi all right so here uh we're going to
pick your jedi character i can be arab
[Music]
real phenology this is funny it's like
reading the menu at an armenian
restaurant
there's also two more uh darcinji i had
that once it made me ill
chose a bra you know what i saw a girl
once you should have chose zebra she had
big ones
so stupid why are we doing this i don't
know
okay here we go who's she she's out of
the jedi let's get started then get
started on what she's took the arms on
her
okay
look at that stair she just did you see
the way she just looked at me yeah yeah
she was like this is on
when do i start fighting oh you'll know
all right start fighting okay i'm back
here no remember yeah remember step
forward and there we go wait move move
back stay on your mark that's why we put
the tape on how many times i have to hit
this guy okay i got this guy right here
oh you could also kick these guys why
did it say move back oh i just hit the
girl and then yeah in the bun
i think they've noticed that we are
idiots
i'm just not going to move forward
what do you think of this game the
action is good uh-huh i don't know why
we're attacking these robots they didn't
seem to do anything to me so that just
seems randomly violent right i've stayed
at this spa this is very nice it's on
the island of kauai it's fantastic oh we
gotta jump down let's jump down all
right this is a dangerous environment oh
hello
can you stand yes i can you've got to
call for reinforcements what did you
just say we got to call reinforcements i
thought you said i had a killer ass well
hold out as long as we can is it me or
she seem a little [ __ ] she's kind of
controlling oh you got to jump go we've
got to get to the tiki line there we go
all right we did it wait one two three i
think one more time
why don't we just keep jumping because
you keep dying just jump on these
platforms they're gonna collapse they
should have put stairs in
how would you read the story of this
game i don't quite know what's happening
so i don't know what we're fighting
about exactly right i don't know what my
relationship is to the woman she seems
attracted to me she's very controlling
but as a catholic i'm kind of into that
all that being said what would you give
this game on the whole the graphics are
great
the uh action's fun i found some of the
movements a little bit confusing and
hard to master i don't love the stepping
forward i think they need to address
that i think they should choose a
different spa setting for the next one
um probably something i don't know in
aspen would be nice they have great spas
yeah out of
14 stars five being great nine being not
great tending excellent
and two being pretty good i give it like
uh i give it like a six and a half if
you can figure out that rating system
you're a better man than i clueless
gamer conan o'brien see you guys next
time
[Music]